port du masque obligatoire gels hydro
alcooliques ou signalétique dans
l'ensemble du bâtiment
le tribunal judiciaire de versailles a
adopté des règles sanitaires
le déconfinement synonyme de reprise de
l'ensemble des activités
juridictionnelles
avec des adaptations c'est le cas des
affaires familiales
habituellement traitée dans un bureau
comme celui ci là il a fallu tout
réorganiser puisque ces audiences là ne
pouvait pas se tenir dans les cabinets
donc on a dû redistribuer tous les
locaux suffisamment vaste de la
juridiction pour que chacun puisse tenir
son activité face aux nombreuses
affaires à traiter certains dossiers
sont déposés au tribunal pour accélérer
le traitement sans passer par une
audience une procédure possible quand
les partis sont représentés par des
avocats lors d'une audience le public
n'est pas acceptée seules les personnes
convoquées sont présentes magistrats
greffiers ministère public ou avocat les
gestes barrières sont respectées entre
chaque personne du côté des affaires
pénales la fin du confinement a entraîné
une recrudescence d'activité il y à la
fois que les infractions commises en
flagrant délit donc plus de liberté
permet plus d'action si je puis dire
donc il ya ce qui se passe en temps réel
et puis il ya aussi un phénomène de
rétro planning je dirais c'est toutes
les affaires qui étaient programmés
avant le confinement et qui ont été
suspendues et pour lesquels les services
d' enquête police et gendarmerie
maintenant peuvent actionner convoquer
les gens et procédé aux actes et ainsi
terminer des affaires donc c'est affaire
arrive évidemment au parquet et
éventuellement devant le tribunal
affaires civiles pénales familiales ou
encore l'application des peines entre
150 et 200 personnes fréquentent en
moyenne chaque jour le tribunal
judiciaire de versailles
environ 300 fonctionnaires et une
centaine de magistrats travaillent sur
place